e Este sou eu não tem eu perdi 25 kg
durante 60 dias apenas jogando na
realidade virtual em
e obrigado marcando isso que eu parei de
fazer os treinos chatos e convencionais
e seguir a minha paixão para vencer este
bem que ano a cinco anos que vive com
obesidade 135 kg baixa autoestima e
nunca consegui mudar mas o que eu não
sabia é que só me faltava juntar dois
ingredientes É verdade finalmente
voltamos aqui ao canal pessoal e tem
sido uma longa Jornada para perder peso
mas se vocês não acharam algo estranho
na minha também outra foto do antes eu
tenho uma tattoo e na foto do depois eu
já não tenho estátua como é que é
possível dar que tu depois tu perdeste
peso e que é que passou aqui isso é
Photoshop vamos começar pelo início eu
sempre fui magra O que é que não pode
haver por esta foto eu sei que parece um
psicopata Mas eu sempre fui magro desse
jeito e na altura senti muito bem quando
me vi ao espelho mas nestes últimos
cinco seis anos ele dá aquela leve em
bordada sabem estar em casa a fazer
vídeos uma receita mais parada enfim eu
tinha perder peso mesmo urgente e eu
tomei essa decisão há um ano atrás
quando realmente eu consegui arranjar
forças para mudar fiz precisamente tudo
o que eu li na internet eu podia ajudar
a perder peso eu comi de forma mais
saudável eu fiz mais treinos fiz muito a
passadeira ocorre muito o corri muito
qualquer bem para chegar aos 75 quilos
Como podem ver por este gráfico aqui
meus e lente fiquei muito orgulhoso de
mim esta foto é de essa altura O que é
que eu aí fiquei muito contente eu
fiquei muito feliz porque é assim eu vou
ter o corpo que eu gostava de ver ao
espelho OK aí fiquei muito mais ativo
muito mais feliz inclusiva nessa altura
com quem mais vídeos também mas está eu
cometi um erro ele só corria e comia
salada com frango porque é foi o que eu
vi na internet e parecemos ser uma dieta
interessante Claro que vai dar bosta dar
Realmente eu fiquei magro Como podem ver
mas eu não usei a minha cabeça gostam
muito rapidamente eu voltei comer
porcarias todas açucares voltei comer o
seu lado tudo e mais alguma coisa dois
litros de coca-cola por dia era uma
coisa Insana eu voltei à estaca zero de
135 kg que é como eu estou nesta
fotografia lindo agora posso barriga tão
bonita adoro tem mais uma vez eu volto
em odiar o meu corpo eu voltei e não me
senti e não é que seja mal ok mas este
não é o meu corpo como eu não mudei a
minha mentalidade gordo pessoal eu
precisava de incluir dentro do meu
exercício e dentro da minha rotina algo
que me motivasse a gostar de fazer
exercício sabem não ser só correndo não
ser só a comer coisas pequenas Porque
isso tem que ser feito a longo prazo
vocês tem que encaixar isso mais você
tem vocês eu em toda a minha história de
tentar perder peso sempre voltei ganhar
e voltei a ganhar voltei ganhei e nunca
fiquei assim que magro como eu gostaria
mas certa vez eu implementei o modo Mark
Zuckerberg eu vou dividir este vídeo e
esta experiência em quatro fases tudo
aquilo que eu fiz então para realmente
perder estes 25 kg e ficar assim magrito
ainda falta mais ok eu não estou no auge
de corpo ideal ok que eu quero para mim
obviamente o vosso corpo ideal a vosso
corpo ideal o meu não é esta ainda e no
final das outras mostrar agora com
quanto peso eu estou aqui pessoal eu não
vi ainda mas eu eu creio que já perdi
mais de 20 kg só que aí no final do
vídeo eu vou revelar a
e
enquanto a minha alimentação pessoal eu
fiz literalmente o que tinha feito já na
dia anterior Mas em vez de cortar
completamente os hidratos que foi o meu
maior erro por isso é que eu perdi peso
tão rápido Ok a dieta low carb faz
sentido que faz mas depois vocês também
perdem muito músculo perdem os
nutrientes ficam fracos ficam de mau
humor Ok desta vez pessoal eu não exclui
os hidratos a continuar comer os
hidratos simplesmente como coisas mais
saudáveis como comida mais limpa arroz
Limpo sem feijão sem bacon como o frango
o impulso tem ser aqueles estrogonofes
com natas e e temperos assim estranho
cheio de açúcar e gordura simplesmente
tem comido mais limpo e principalmente
adicionei nos hidratos a minha dieta Mas
acima de tudo eu não fiz um corte brusco
eu continuo aí o comer o que eu comi que
dá mais ou menos umas duas mil e 400
calorias por dia OK que não que não é
nada mal é bom até sempre me senti com
energia com força e não cometer o erro
que tenha cometido algum atraso porque
depois para engordar muito fácil é muito
fácil enfim e a vontade mas não à
vontadinha o que me faz ficar mais ativo
e consistente outra coisa importante
água voz pa bota bebi muito mais água
foi mais vezes à casa-de-banho é normal
mas faz toda a diferença eu na altura só
para vocês terem uma noção a única água
que eu devia era do café que eu usava
como pré-treino ou seja bebi um café e a
Correr em jejum atualmente já não faço
isso eu tenho como algo um pouco antes
de atenção eu não estou a tentar
recomendar o que eu fiz ok É porque eu
não sou nutricionista eu Talvez possa
ter feito alguma coisa errado eu só vou
explicar o que eu fiz para mim para
levar isto adianta Ok eu não perdi peso
só para os [ __ ] eu até disse que quer
dizer que oitenta por cento da minha
perca de peso foi devido a minha
alimentação aquela alimentação é
importante a matemática é muito simples
eu só tive que comer menos do que o que
o meu corpo gasta ou então se eu comer
muito tem que treinar para gastar mais
do que aquilo que eu comi ela lembre-se
sempre faz
[Música]
musculação muito importante que falo por
e quando estamos a perder peso a
tendência do corpo começar a comer tudo
a cultura os músculos começaram a ficar
assim todo na igreja por eu não queria
ir só que dessa vez eu estou conseguindo
definir melhor o meu corpo o ombro já
está a sair os meus biceps também já
estão assim está a ficar com corpo
estético Ok não é só a Card e comer
salada com com peito de frango sabe
vamos passar muito importante porque
também aumentar as calorias que você
gasta diariamente e isso é muito bom
porque enquanto vocês dormem por ali
gastar tal enquanto eu tô aqui sentada a
fazer espelho o meu cartão e queimar
calorias kkk enquanto eu estou jogar
Talita kkkk kkkk e musculação uso do
Matinho desta vez eu treinar mas não
tanto como treinava na altura porque eu
substitui um pouco de treino de
musculação para o treino de óculos de ar
e porque precisamente para não sentir
essa pressão que tem que levantar pesos
eu tenho que fazer exercício porque às
vezes não acontece Às vezes eu
levanto-me não quer fazer peso Ok então
game e ficar o meu meu exercício faz com
que o No próximo dia tenho vontade de
fazer porque sei que vou jogar porque
essa a minha vontade eu E então como
está a delegada todo o exercício como um
todo que vai aparecer fazer não sei
porque mas isso em mim resultou Mas onde
é que faz uma expulsão e o que tu vais a
ginástica que eu faço em casa como é que
faz eu fiz o mais rápido possível e ele
entra aumente comprei dois halteres e
como devo fazer em casa só com isso
exercícios básicos cliente tranquilaço e
lá fez uma luz no cabelo azul passatempo
passar uma motivação fogo e agora eu vou
por também e já começar a fazer peso mas
eu não tenho que ir aí agora daqui agora
vamos sempre eles façam com arroz e o
que é poder comer uma coisa agora é para
comer o pão era bem assim na cama
massa serve mas é o perfeito ó
nós temos aqui 3 quilos em 3 que o
dinheiro lá
o
PT olha só
a
chover é muito simples e fácil
agora sim pessoal vamos passar a
novidade como eu realmente perder muitas
calorias a fazer o que eu amo que é
vídeo é o jovem Apesar dele não gravar
tanto para o canal de jogos e tudo mais
eu passo e muitas horas a chegar por dia
eu digo que tipo umas 6 horas por dia a
jogar Ok olha só primeiro jogo dos
óculos de aro 26 é um jogo onde vocês
têm que acompanhar o ritmo da música
enquanto cortam assim umas peças com
slides a iva está bem se vocês tiverem o
que eles vieram em casa e jogarem esse
jogo eu duvido que vocês consigam chegar
ao fim de uma música sem soar Este é um
dos principais jogos que me fez perder
peso Ok era
E aí
[Música]
E o Nelson a ficar difícil né
[Aplausos]
é ou não é
[Música]
[Aplausos]
e
[Música]
pronto não
então não é
[Aplausos]
E aí
e
olha
contrário porque o mate alguma
para aumentar as calorias perdidas vamos
misturar a música mais rápida super
fácil de sonda agora vai ai meu Deus é
E ai meu Deus é
[Música]
E aí
é muito difícil né
e
como não é
E aí
E ai meu Deus vamos nos braços tudo aqui
parece um valor
eu nunca tinha experimentado este modo
assim mais rápido mas eu vou começar a
usar tenho 30 olha a pizza
olha tô indo corpo vou lá só Esse sim é
o meu jogo favorito é o que eu tenho
chegado mais tempo este jogo Xbox aqui a
minha prestação não vai ser muito alta
porque já tinha os braços muito cansados
de ter jogado aqui que sai agora OK mas
vamos acabar então aqui nossa rotina de
carne com este ou este o insano tão só
ou não ó ó
e é muito importante fazer
essa é difícil eu tenho 10 anos mas ele
não tem nada
não é
eu
sou super fã número 1
E aí
e se acabou na vida deste rapaz aqui ó
o limitante juro eu não sou tão forte
mas essencialmente ainda não é joga joga
o sobre isso é o homem gelatina de
alemães Não
este é o mais complicado vou ganhar cá
olha só que me aproxima viu Já percebi o
meu Deus ela tá muito mal Olha esse
Penteado estás pronto só aqui
tá com cara tem que ter mostrar o
açúcar poder Cala cala cala a
E
aí
atrás e
E aí
o treinador do som é onde estão morrendo
Isso é uma toca rock eu não vou deixar
eu não aguento mais as grandes mudar o
último sono e
Oi Vi Vi
e bora lá pessoal eu tô muito cansado
mas vou ter que me despir agora que é
para ter o peso real hoje ainda não come
nada oque portanto eu estou em jejum O
que quer dizer que o meu peso real é o
que vai aparecer agora OK Normalmente
quando vocês bebem muita água ou comem
pelo menos uma refeição o vosso pesosa
varia entre 1 a 2 kg dependendo do que
Vocês comeram Ok mas se eu estou em
jejum portanto eu não tenho nada mais no
meu corpo o peso que vai marcar é o meu
peso real Ok e vamos ver eu tô curioso o
[Música]
O
Curioso
Calma aí já deu um sorriso neste momento
apesar
E aí já vibrou
105kg
por cento de gordura pessoal estou muito
feliz finalmente conseguir chegar aos 65
novamente com esta técnica obrigada a
minha namorada para mim ter ajudado
muito a conseguir isto em 60 dias apenas
com óculos Viar boa alimentação e alguma
musculação pouca mas eu coloquei também
eu consegui voltar para os 65kg com
vocês podem ver aqui já está definir
muito melhor o ombro aqui uma pescoço
estes ótimos aqui já estou a começar a
aparecer mas eu não vou revelar o meu
corpo por inteiro ao que é pessoal
porque ainda vou fazer mais um projeto a
seguir a este para definir tudo e só e
aqueles vou revelar o meu corpo Ok
espero que tenha incentivar alguém a
fazer exercício ou se vocês estão
desmotivados e tão pouco acima do peso
eu possa talvez ajudar essa motivação
Vou agora tomar aquele banho e talvez
fazer uma refeição beliche para festejar
pessoal os 65 quilos meu para mim é uma
conquista enorme Mas agora vamos tentar
chegar aos 85 e tenta e definir o nosso
corpo Ok fiquei À Espera de um novo
projeto para definir aí se eu vou
revelar aqui o meu Carrapicho e já está
bem votamos O que é o canal por dentro
de um ser vídeos regularmente comenta
embaixo que vocês querem ver pessoal e
Obrigado também a minha namorada já foi
embora mas ela me ajudou muito também a
conseguir isto o meu só o fato dela não
comer porcaria ao meu lado Já ajudei
imenso meu psicológico e elas for
Siemens a fazer isso tipo ela podia
comer umas bolachas ou é umbilical a
qualquer coisa assim que ela pode comer
de facto ela escondia de mim para eu não
haverá comer e não sentir aquela pressão
psicológica de também comer um doce e
esse foi muito importante mesmo do valor
a isso mas é isso Pessoal espero que
tenham gostado se quiser ver mais vídeos
como este mente aí fiquem bem e até a
próxima